foreign
[Music]
so how big would Godzilla be in -1 now
this is the question that many of you
will have after seeing the new tohotiza
for the movie what we are going to do is
analyze the footage and compare it with
what his usual body proportions and
specifications are and with that we will
get a good rough estimate on how big he
would be we will also discuss his
General body design as seen in the
poster and teaser and to sugarcoat it
all we will compare him to other
contemporary Godzillas seen in recent
times as well as a couple of classic
designs one from the show era one from
the heisei era and a millennium as well
so let's get into it let's start with
the teaser and the footage showing his
tail swiping away buildings and people
in the streets when we pause or slow the
scene to the mags we can see to the side
Godzilla's left leg right beside a
three-story building so with each story
of an RCC building being on average 3
meters or 10 feet tall that would put
the top of the building at 10 meters
right under the bent knee of a slouched
Godzilla then next we will look at a
less obscured scene of the G-Man at
least less obscured parts of him we see
one of his feet stomping the ground and
sending Rubble on Earth all around
cracking the surface and crushing
everyone underneath just by looking at
it we can assess that one of his toe
claws would be around 3 meters or one
story in size around twice that of an
average Japanese man in the 1940s who
were around 5 feet or 1.5 meters in
height yeah imagine a toe being twice
your size
so saving the best evidence for laws we
will now look at the last scene of him
about to bite that train just like he
did in the original movie this would
definitely be a wolf of the Wall Street
pointing scene anyway this is actually
the first time we would see his head and
face as well being terrified not unlike
the ride's design but at the same time
different as are all Godzillas they
share similarities with one another
while at the same time having unique
nuanced elements anyway compared to the
train which we can barely see we can
still make out that the train car is
roughly half the size of his mouth that
would put his head in a size range of 9
meters or 30 feet yeah I know it seems
like I'm spitting out the same numbers
again and again but I gotta be true you
know what I see is what I see
so since we don't have a full body image
of the -1 gujira yet we shall take the
rights version for this which he really
is based upon estimating his body height
and tail is going to be quite alright as
well anyway what do we have those sides
at 3 meters or 10 feet okay bent knee at
33 feet or 10 meters from the ground and
a head at 9 meters or 30 feet in size
assessing the scale on the full image we
will take the parts and compare them to
one another head to knee toe to knee
just to see if they all match up and
yeah what we have seems to be a good
approximation now let's do this our way
again just as we assess the size of the
dragons on House of the Dragon in an
earlier video we will take Godzilla's
head copy paste it and put one on top of
another till they reach the height of
the full body now here we have roughly
six and a half heads and with each of
them being 9 meters or 30 feet in size
we therefore get a total of 195 feet of
15 9 meters so rounding it off we have
Godzilla minus one here standing around
200 feet or 60 meters tall
anyway what does his body design say
since Takashi yamazaki the writer and
director of the movie has worked on
Sunset on 3rd Street and the Godzilla
ride we can safely say that he likes his
Godzillas a bit brown in color rather
than the blackish gray with bluish tones
which are the norm well aside from Shin
who is red this Godzilla seems to look
more menacing with a bumpy skin and an
angrier look and having more rough
osterdames all over his body with
rougher scales which seems to look like
Barnacles of some sort he seems to
resemble something of a combination of
the most of us slightly and also of the
Hasty designs while also taking the
original into context they did say that
this Godzilla will bring back the horror
elements and yeah he does thus the
reason why he looks more evil not as
much as Shin though in my personal
opinion even his dorsal spines are scary
they are more of the Hasty design but
they have more prominent divisions
between them and also sharper tips
but what do we really know about his
overall body well if he is really based
on the Godzilla rights design which he
might be since Takashi yamazaki did work
on that as well he will have a similar
body proportions and well not much of a
difference from all other normal
Godzilla's frames two trunky legs medium
length arms with sharp claws a long tail
and he won't be fat like Godzilla 2014.
so talking about the devil we shall
begin with a comparison comparing -1 to
GVK most of us Godzilla here we have a
120 meters tall Behemoth the most of us
won against a new Godzilla which is half
the height starting at an estimation of
60 meters or 200 feet
as we said earlier we will compare him
to other Godzillas as well now comparing
him to shin and we get the same result
as Shin Godzilla is 119 meters tall just
one meter shy of the monster verse
version comparing -1 to singular points
we still get a large difference SP
single point has a bulkier body set on
dinosaurian legs Ultima which is his
final form has a height of 100 meters or
328 feet 40 meters taller than -1
comparing him to the original 1954
Godzilla is more of a fairer deal 1954
Gojira is 50 meters or 164 feet tall
which is 10 meters or 33 feet shorter
than this new king of the monsters the
Hasty version depends on the movie
Godzilla here ranges from 80 meters to
100 meters so -1 will be either 20
meters or 40 meters shorter than his
hazy counterpart and lastly comparing -1
to the Millennium versions well we see
them both at roughly the same size with
the previous incarnations
being around 55 meters to 60 meters in
size the same as -1
so that's that I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit the like
button for support and subscribe to push
us through the YouTube algorithm however
it may work but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates and new
videos here on this channel take care
fam